we've already touched on ethers in
several videos they've been our useful
aprotic solvents in several of our
reactions but i thought it was about
time that we actually devoted a video or
two to ethers and like all things that
we've done in organic chemistry a good
way to familiarize ourselves with the
molecules and how they look is to
actually name them so let's do a couple
and the first few you've seen already so
let's say we have this molecule
right here
this molecule right here what i'm going
to do is i'm going to teach you two ways
to name it the common name and that's
probably the more important one
especially with ethers because as you
could imagine that is the more common
name that is what people say and then
i'll also show you how to name it using
the iupac
name so let me let me write this down i
u p a c name which is the international
union of pure and applied chemistry and
they come up with kind of the official
the official naming protocols for all of
these organic molecules and these this
is actually the convention that we used
earlier when we did the alkanes and the
alkenes but in the case of ethers the
common name is more common so the common
name for this molecule right here you
look at the two carbon groups here so
let's see you have this one right here
that is an ethyl group
that's an ethyl group right there you
have one two carbons and then you look
at the other carbon group
right over there that's also an ethyl
group you have one
two carbons so you call this let me just
write this down that is also an ethyl
group so the common name for this
the common name for this is just diethyl
ether
diethyl
ether and the ether tells you
this part tells you that you have an
oxygen in between your two ethyl groups
this is the common name
common name
now the international union of pure and
applied chemistry official name for it
you kind of do something similar to how
we named other things before you look
for the longest chain let me redraw it
you look so maybe on the left hand side
i'll do the common names on the right
hand side i'll do the iupac names
so let's let me redraw
what the common name of the diethyl
ether you look for the longest chain in
this case there's two longest chains
there's this one that has one two
carbons and then you have this one that
has one two carbons you could pick
either one i'll just pick this one as
the main chain
right over there
it has two carbons no double bonds it is
it is an ethane
it is
ethane and then you say okay i have this
i have this alkoxy group and we call
that
we put the oxy at the end of it because
it has this oxygen right here but it
it's it's the the alkyl part of it has
two carbons one two so we call this
right here we call this ethoxy
ethoxy so one other way to name this we
have this ethoxy group attached to the
one carbon we're just going to start
numbering on this side of the ethane
just because that's where the group is
attached to the one carbon so we call
this one ethoxy ethane
so this is one
ethoxy
ethoxyethane you'll almost never see it
actually named this way even though this
is the official name you're much more
likely to see this as diethyl ether and
at least in my brain this resonates a
lot more you just say what what are the
two groups and you throw the ether at
the end you know that there's an oxygen
in between let's do a couple more of
these so let's say i have this molecule
right here
i have this molecule
right over here the common way is you
look at the two groups on either side of
the oxygen
so this right here
let me do this in a different color
this group on the left right here we
have one two three carbons it's a propyl
group but we're attached to that middle
carbon so this is an isopropyl group
iso
isopropyl group and on the right hand
side right here we just have one carbon
so this is right here i keep using that
blue
this right here
this is a methyl group
this is a methyl group so the common way
of naming it you just list both of these
groups and then you write ether and you
list them in alphabetical order i comes
before m so this is the common name is
isopropyl
methyl
isopropyl methyl
ether
isopropyl
methyl ether now if we were to do the
iupac naming we look for the longest
carbon chain let me redraw the molecule
itself
so that let me redraw the same thing
right there so what's the longest carbon
chain here well we have one two three
carbons right there we only have one
carbon right there so this thing right
here is our longest carbon chain it has
three carbons on it so it is and had no
double bonds so f meth probe propyl or
it's actually propane so this is our
longest so we write propane
right there because we're using the
iupac naming mechanism and then we look
at this
this
methoxy group right here and i call this
a methoxy group because i have the o
that gives us the oxy and i just have a
methyl group right here so this is
methoxy
methoxy you remember that meth is the
prefix for just having only one carbon
we add the oxy because that oxygen is
there and it's attached to the two
carbon on the propane chain no matter
what direction you start naming from or
numbering from one
two
three so this is two methoxy propane
methoxy
two
methoxypropane let's do another one
let's do one more and i think you'll get
the the the gist of at least the
reasonably simple ethers to name so
let's put a let's put a
let's put
a
ring over there
and then that's attached to an oxygen
and then we have another carbon chain
right here
right there let me just copy and paste
that so that i don't have to redraw it
so let me copy
and paste all right so let's do the
common name first that always tends to
be a little bit more fun
so on this side we have one two three
four five
six carbons in a cycle this right here
on the left hand side is a cyclohexyl
group
cyclocyclohexyl group this on the right
hand side
we have one two three this is just a
straight up propyl group propyl
propyl group and so when you name the
ether you just put these two groups in
alphabetical order and you add an ether
at the end so cyclohexyl
c comes before p
so it's cyclocycle
propyl
let me get that shade of yellow right
cyclohexyl propyl
ether
cyclohexyl propyl ether now let's do the
iupac way to name it so you look for the
longest carbon chain here in this case
it's going to be the cyclohexane right
here we have one two three four five six
carbons there we only have one two three
there so this is kind of our backbone so
we write down cyclohexane
cyclohexane
no double bonds it's a hexane so that's
the cyclohexane right there if you just
had
if you just had these three carbons it
would be a propyl but this is not just
three carbons it's three carbons and
then an oxygen so we would call it a
propoxy
so this is propoxy group
pro propoxy
and you don't have to number it because
it can just be attached to any of these
carbons it would essentially be the same
molecule so you could just call this
propoxycyclohexane
propoxy
let me make it a little bit closer to
the cyclohexane
propoxy
propoxy cyclohexane but once again the
common name is what you're more likely
to see now that we've named a few of
them let's think a little bit about
their properties
so what we've seen already is that and
we've used it several times especially
in our sn2 reactions and things like
that places where we didn't need it
where we didn't want protons floating
around we use actually diethyl ether and
in general ethers do make for good
solvents they tend to be fairly
unreactive
so good
good solvents especially when you're
looking for an aprotic solvent remember
aprotic means you don't have hydrogens
that can kind of
lose their electron to maybe electro an
electronegative atom like an oxygen and
then the proton just floats around and
then can go and react with other things
this does not have any hydrogens
directly bonded to an oxygen in any of
these cases so it is an aprotic solvent
and because it doesn't have any
hydrogens bonded to the oxygen you also
have no hydrogen bonding and just as a
bit of review
you know that in water you have the
situation let me draw some water
molecules
in water you have this situation
where the oxygen hogs the electron so it
has a partial negative charge hydrogen
gets its its electrons hogged or taken
away or
it spends less time with them so it's a
partial positive charge
so this oxygen will have a partial
negative charge and so
the hydrogens with the partial positive
charge are attracted to the oxygens with
the partial negative charge and you have
this hydrogen bonding and this hydrogen
bonding makes water
it pulls the molecules together so you
need to put more energy into it for it
to
either melt or for it to actually boil
and for the molecules to kind of get
ripped away from each other and that's
also true with alcohols alcohols only
have a height one hydrogen to each
oxygen but they still have the hydrogen
bonding going on in the case
in the case of ethers there is no
hydrogen bonding i'll represent each of
the carbon chains with an r and an r
i'll write r prime right here to show
that it could it could be a different
carbon chain than this right here
and the r stands for radical not to be
confused with free radical completely
different things this r just means
really a carbon chain attached to this
oxygen but here there's no
there's no there's no hydrogen getting
its electrons hogged by oxygens with
partial positive and partial negative
charges so you're not going to have that
type of hydrogen bonding and because of
that ethers have much lower melting and
boiling points it's much easier you have
to put less heat into the system for
these molecules to break away from each
other because they aren't attracted to
each other as much